ladies and gentlemen dr. Jordan Peterson
[Applause]
[Applause]
nor we didn't say no one further
extroverted enthusiasm that's pretty
sweet coming out to that huh yeah that's
for sure
alright so here's what we're gonna do I
want to go through some of the the big
questions that I've come up with during
the last five or six months on the road
with you which have just been an
incredible truly life-changing time for
me and then we're gonna end with oslo's
best question you got 45 minutes in you
will see all right so first off so first
off every single night you are different
and I think tonight perhaps different
more different than any night so far how
the hell do you do it I honestly don't
know I you know I usually go back in the
green room with you for a little bit
before and about 10 and 10 minutes
before showtime I walk out of there and
you say you need to think for a little
bit and then you somehow do an hour and
a half summing up everything you think
in a different way on any given night
well there's some I'll answer that
technically you know the first thing is
is that something I tell my students you
know if if you want to write an essay
you need a problem because the essay is
an attempt to solve a problem so first
of all you need a problem and then
second if you're gonna devote time to
the problem then it should be like it
should be a problem that is your problem
at least a piece of it should be you
know I have students all the time and
they come up to me and they say tell me
what I should write my essay about and
they're often very annoyed that I
haven't you know you didn't give us a
topic it's like yes that's because the
topic is the difficult part of the
assignment right to specify the problem
that's the difficult part of the
assignment in fact when you're trying to
when you're trying to address a complex
that's a domain of suffering the
diagnosis which is the problem
formulation is the crucial cognitive
step so if you want to write you need a
problem and and if you want to write
truthfully then you need a problem
that's yours
and if you want to write in a focused
and aimed manner then you unite your
thinking around the problem and so one
thing I always do before when I sit
backstage as I think okay what's the
problem for tonight you know and the
problem for tonight was victim so what's
one statements like okay let's explore
the concept of victim and go down as far
as we possibly can okay so then well
then I would say but I have my knowledge
organized in a do synchronic manner and
that's a consequence of having spent
when I wrote my first book which was
maps of meaning I wrote every day for
three hours for 15 years and I vowed
when I started that I was going to make
that what would you say the highest duty
that I had nothing was going to come
before that and there's a certain amount
of cruelty in that because it meant that
you know if my wife came into my office
then I would bark at her and if my kids
came into my office like a junkyard dog
surrounded by barbed wire it's like
because you can always not right it's
not that important that day and there
might be more pressing concerns and
there probably are including people who
would just like to have something to do
with you for a while or do something
nicer have a problem fixed it's like no
go away I've got three hours and so ice
ice ice I was a thief and I took that
from my life and so I spent a very long
time writing and thinking about the
hardest problem that I could
conceptualize and that was the
relationship between the individual and
the atrocity committed in the service of
totalitarian possession it was the worst
problem I could think of how so I looked
to see what the worst thing people could
do under the worst circumstances
was and tried to figure out why that
happened that was step one and step two
was having come to some determination
about how it might happen then and
having learned something that I had
suspected all along which was that that
capacity was part of the individual
right me as well as everyone else to
determine if there was a mode of acting
in the world that would restrict that
possibility so that it would no longer
manifest itself and so I spent however
many hours 45,000 hours thinking about
that and that's not right because that's
how much time I spent writing about it
most of that time because I have a very
obsessive mind in some sense I lock on a
problem I can't let it go or it can't
let me go I don't know which way to
think about it and so it wasn't only
that I was writing for three hours a day
I was thinking about it all the time
right from the time I woke up till the
time I went to sleep and I was reading
about it obsessively you know I read a
tremendous amount when I was in graduate
school and so the reason I'm telling you
all of that is Dancer this question is
like then I spent 30 years lecturing
about it and you know I started out with
my lectures fairly structured because I
was still wrestling with the ideas but I
tried over the years to reduce the
amount of scaffolding safety wire
netting that was underneath me while I
was lecturing until I got to the point
where I didn't need to do anything other
than sit for 10 minutes and think okay
what's the problem where am I going I'm
exploring a solution I'm not necessarily
putting forward a pre constructed
solution like it'll be in the universe
of solutions I've considered but I'd
like to get it sharper and clearer so I
got to the point where I could go from
the problem through the story using all
these things that I had already talked
about and knew and so then I can
sequence them and I think the closest
analogy I can think of is jazz
improvisation it's something like that
you know a next
musician has a tremendous number of
habits deeply ingrained like an athlete
same thing that that are part-and-parcel
built into to to him or her and so I
have that and so then I can come out and
think okay well a little of this and a
little of that and that's new it's like
each of these ideas is a personality of
sorts and you can let them have a
dialogue in real time and see where it
goes and that's a story right that's
what a great author does when he writes
a book is he puts out some characters
and then he lets the characters do
whatever they would do and that reveals
the story and so I kind of do that I let
the ideas do what they're going to do
and see how they fight and compete with
one another and and and then that's see
what people wanted a lecture is assuming
that this is a lecture and it probably
isn't it's probably more like a strange
sort of dialogue with the audience what
what people want in a forum like this is
they want to see thought in action right
they don't want to see something that's
already crystallized and and and dead
which is why I did read the last time I
was here although I do that rarely they
want to see something they want to see
well what they want to see technically
speaking is something if you thought
about metaphysically is they want to see
the logos in action that's really what
people always want to see and I mean
that philosophically and so the
real-time part of it the fact that it's
not a contrived performance is actually
crucial to its success and also what
keeps me engaged like it's I don't know
how these damn lectures are gonna go
when I come out here I think okay victim
man that's a big problem okay well we
could we could address it with this and
then we could use this and and I can
play those together and we can see how
that goes and then perhaps I'll bill to
draw a rousing conclusion because it's
hard to bring that to the point at the
end you know successfully something I've
got better out over the tour which is
quite fun but I never don't know if
it's gonna work and so I'm on edge when
I come out on stage I think oh my god
I've got a big problem here and I've got
to sort it out 70 minutes and there's
all these people here so and and that
makes it really tense for me in an
exciting way it's an exhilarating
you know it's an exhilarating challenge
but that also makes it alive because I
could easily fail so well so that's how
it's lots of practice and and then the
final thing is I don't talk about
problems that don't matter to me
they matter this victim thing that
matters it's important it's fundamental
and so every night I come out and I
think okay well what's the fundamental
problem for tonight and it's a problem
that affects me as far as deep down as
as I can go you know and so yeah do you
know the point in life when you became a
serious person and I mean yes I mean
that in the best sense of it because
when people ask me what it's like to be
on tour with you yeah I always say well
he takes life seriously and it's making
me take life more seriously and I think
it's making these people take life more
seriously do you remember the moment
that that happened yes can you tell me
that moment yes I can yeah so it was in
I think 1983 and this is a strange story
I came home from a party University
party and I wasn't in the best mood I've
always had a certain proclivity towards
depression which I've recently
discovered is probably an autoimmune
problem in any case I'd gone to this
party and I'd had a lot to drink because
I like to drink and I don't know I
wasn't happy with with something that
happened at the party wasn't happy with
the way I behaved I mean that's not
uncommon right if you if you like to
drink and you're not happy with the way
he behaved those things just go together
and so but there was it was deeper than
that it wasn't just that I was
I'm happy with the way the party had
gone but I was deeply dissatisfied with
how I was oriented in life like I felt
that I felt that there was a it was a
nihilism I suppose that was that was
gnawing at me this was not long after
I'd stopped I'd worked for a Socialist
Party in Canada for a while when I was a
kid and this wasn't long after I stopped
doing that and so I kind of lost my
moorings and you know that the
Christianity that my mother practiced in
particular I'd abandoned that when I was
like 13 and so I didn't have any
structured orient me at all
and and so I was experimenting a little
bit with artistic production at this
point not a lot but a bit and so I took
out this canvas from my my closet and I
sat down and I sketched out this picture
and I just let my imagination roam and
what came out was it was a crucifixion
then there was a I drew a picture of
Christ on the on the crucifixion but it
with a very judgmental face very angry
face and with a snake wrapped around his
waist and it was really harsh picture it
was like an expressionist picture not
that I have the talent of an
expressionist but but but that's what it
was and I thought I mean I wasn't
thinking I didn't think that I was
thinking in religious terms at that
point at all and you know I was an
absolutely sporadic churchgoer
and I was absolutely shocked by this
picture I thought what what where the
hell did this come from what did that
possibly mean you know I took me years
to figure out what it meant
I mean really good one one thing so I'll
tell you part of what it meant so Carl
Jung said something very interesting
about the structure of the New Testament
he said that the gospel Christ is
fundamentally although not entirely
fundamentally a figure of compassion but
the ideal is not only compassion the
ideal is also a judge because an ideal
is a judge you know let's say you have
an ideal
well it's a judge because you don't live
up to it and so your ideal is always
looking at you like you're not what you
should be and the higher the ideal the
more judgmental the judge well that's
what he thought the book of Revelation
first of all emerged in me as an
unconscious revelation which because
Christ comes back at the end of time so
so the story goes as the ultimate judge
and virtually no one is judged
acceptable well why well because by the
highest possible see speaking
psychologically you can biologically for
that matter the idea of Christ is the
instantiation of the ideal as such
that's what it is no it might be more
than that but that's what it is it's
it's whatever a human being would be if
a human being was perfect and it's an
effort of our collective imagination to
represent that symbolically which we do
with cathedrals for example when we
paint the image of Christ against the
dome that represents eternity itself
that's the ideal now you might say well
I don't believe in the ideal it's like
you missing the point you missing the
point and so so that ideal is a judge
and the farther you are away from that
ideal the harsher the judge and so the
snake was part of that because the thing
is is that if you're low enough and the
ideal is high enough the ideal itself is
so judgmental and so detached for you
that it starts to look to you like your
enemy and so that was the painting and
it was like and I was asking a question
that was the thing that I was asking the
question I was asking like what would I
have to do to set this what would I have
to do to set the situation that I'm in
right and so then I drew this picture
and the picture hell had had the answer
I mean artistic production always has
the answer that's where the answers come
from you know and so that was a
manifestation of imagination it was it
was part of me attempting in its
symbolic mode of personified thinking to
deliver a message
and so I I swore that night that I was
going to do whatever it took
set myself right period whatever and I
was dead serious about that and so that
was the that was the moment and then I
don't know what I did with that picture
I hid it in my closet because I was so
freaked out by I thought what the hell
is this it's like some schizophrenic
nightmare it's like underneath the
covers with that thing but that was the
that knot was it wasn't long after that
that I wrote the first essay that
eventually turned into this maps of
meaning book it was a poem to begin with
actually that was how it came about
first so that's when I decided to be to
straighten myself out regardless of to
straight myself out that's what I was
gonna do so so I think this is our 13th
show in Europe we've got a couple more
over the next couple days and now it
sounds like we're extending for another
30 or 40 probably in the spring I mean
this thing has just grown and grown and
grown are you shocked at the amount of
people that live in Western societies
here in Norway especially when we were
in Sweden a couple days ago but all the
countries that we've been in that live
in free societies yet are completely
afraid to say what they think is easy
absolutely shocking to you I think the
most I think what I've been most shocked
about in all of that is what's happened
in the UK with the police starting to
prosecute people for crimes of
offensiveness that's just and I think
that's probably partly because I'm and I
mean I see that as broadly reflective of
something that's happening in the West
in general but it's particularly
shocking and appalling to me as a
Western Canadian no because obviously
counted that was part of the British
Empire and when I grew up like there was
a pretty tight affinity still in Western
Canada with the British Empire I mean
our maps were the Dominion of Canada it
was still pink you know it was still
part of the British Empire we saying god
save the queen
constantly at public gatherings that's
going by the wayside and so and you know
I've always regarded British common law
and the British
mentoree tradition as well one of it
perhaps the highest achievement of
Western civilization I mean you could
argue about that but it's it's in the
top ten let's say and then to see the
Brits who also have this phenomenal
sense of humor this ability to say
anything no matter how outrageous about
anyone and to include themselves in the
joke right which is such an elegant way
of expressing comedic freedom to see
them going down this road it's just it
just it's it's it's what is it exactly
well it's deeply saddening that's for
sure and and what's horrifying and
that's not exactly the right word I
don't know what the word for it is
there's certainly sorrow that's
associated with a disbelief it's also
that at watching that happen in what I
still think is like the central core of
the idea of individual sovereignty and
freedom as expressed across the Western
world and so and then there's similar
manifestations of that everywhere else
but the police for prosecuting people
for you know asking people to turn in
their neighbors if they say something
offensive and that's happening in in the
UK
yeah littered what we saw that that you
know somebody sent me posters pictures
of posters in the in the Scottish subway
in the in the Metro in the tube you know
saying inviting people to inform on
their neighbors for being offensive it's
like what what the hell what what so I
knew this was coming because because I
knew we brought our first hate speech
laws in in Canada back in the 1980s we
were after this character named Ernst
zündel who is a particularly despicable
piece of work hard hat wearing
right-wing anti-semite
Holocaust denier you know he had it all
that guy and you know it was his
shenanigans careless malevolent
shenanigans that enticed Canadians into
producing
speech legislation I thought no that's
that's not good it's not good you're
making a big mistake we're gonna pay for
this it's gonna unfold over a long time
who defines hate the crucial issue it's
not like it's a scientific category to
judgment and the answer is those whom
you least want to have the power to
define it because they're the ones that
will take that power to themselves and
if you think that isn't gonna affect
what you get to say well you've got
another thing coming so I think it's I
think it's we're gonna pay for it and
hopefully hopefully will wake up and
push back before we have to pay too high
a price we're gonna pay for it so yeah
and we're gonna deserve to pay for it
too
he's talking to you what you know last
night last night I was on this British
show called question time which is very
famous British show and there was a
woman parliamentarian there from Ireland
who it was pretty bright I liked
listening to her but the the host asked
me about this character named count dank
EULA I don't know if you know about him
his girlfriend he's a comedian well he
thinks he's a comedian and well but you
know there are lots of comedians who
think they're comedians that aren't
funny
and and I'm not saying he's not funny
cuz other people think that he's a
comedian too but he presents himself as
a comedian count dank EULA I mean that's
actually a joke that name and his
girlfriend had a pug and I liked count
dank ulam because he hated that pug and
I'm not very fond of pugs I think
they're hideous little creatures and and
and you know I don't really hate them if
a pug comes along and I'll pet it and
everything but it's just sort of like
the the this little rat like dog with
these bugs but you know if you hit a pug
the back of the head the eyes will pop
out and so because they've been so
genetically mishandled and so I don't
know man it's just you do realize we're
putting this on YouTube and you're just
uh you're unleashing a whole world the
hate from the bug people whatever
whatever so you can have your Pug in you
can love my dad had this dog that was so
damn hideous and useless that it was
just a miracle and he loved it to death
and so and you know that's fine that's
fine but and there's kind of an ironic
attitude in in the dismissal of pugs and
dank EULA didn't like his girlfriend's
pug and so he thought he played a mean
trick and or a mean slash funny trick
and teach it to do a Heil Hitler salute
which I actually thought was quite funny
it's like I don't look I don't see that
as glorifying Hitler it's a pug for
God's sake it wasn't that it wasn't uh
what do you call those Doberman you know
it was a pug that's like teaching a rat
to do a Heil Hitler salute I love that
this has come down to the breed of dog
with you
well these things matter in terms of
their of the way they're represented you
know and then you know he taught it to
it's so horrible he and I'm gonna be so
killed for this he taught it to do its
little salute when he said gasps the
Jews which is not funny
you know except it's horribly funny you
know that's the thing well look and so
yeah you laugh that's right because
you're all horrible and you know and you
know perfectly well that it's horribly
funny
and you know we need we need to be able
to be horribly funny because life is
horrible and we and we need to be able
to find we need to be able to allow
people the freedom to find the ability
to transcend that horror with comedy and
a mark of a free society is that
comedians can be just exactly what the
arse which they're people who push the
edge of what's acceptable if you're a
brilliant comedian you get right to the
edge right and you dance there and the
audience is thinking Oh Sarah
Silverman's a good example of that you
know cuz you can just see her she's got
all politically correct recently but
when she was in her heyday you could
just see Sarah she's so smart you'd see
her sitting there and she'd think of
something just spectacularly evil and
horrible and she think oh and then she
say it you know and everyone would just
crack up because like the darkest part
of their soul had once thought something
like that and she dared to utter it and
and by uttering it she also
simultaneously transcended it you know
and that's the beauty of comedy
and-and-and well so anyways they they
went after Dane Killa and nailed him
legally and I thought that's and that's
in Great Britain as well and last night
so they brought this up one on question
time and you know the the Irish woman
said she went off on a talk about how
terrible crystal nacht was and what an
awful thing ash woods and Holocaust was
it's like well
it's it's you not that morally virtuous
to notice that you know you know what I
mean it's like and it didn't have
anything to do with the topic at hand
it's like yeah
you wouldn't say that you noticed that
unless you were implying that were
people there are people around you
including this count dank EULA who
didn't notice that okay it had nothing
to do with whether he should have been
prosecuted for his stupid joke and me
you can say well you could say it was a
stupid joke which it certainly was you
could say that it was a hateful joke
which I don't agree with by the way but
you could say that and I think you could
you can make a credible case for that
but then to say that because you think
that the Holocaust was bad
he should be criminally prosecuted it's
like no sorry man you've crossed the
line and and there's no excuse for it
and so that's part of what's worrisome
about the state of discourse in in the
free West that same thing comedians
won't go to university campuses it's the
same thing you don't get to be funny
so if you can't be funny then you're not
free
you know the gesture in the Kings courts
the only person who gets to tell the
truth and if the King is such a tyrant
that he kills this gesture then you know
that the evil king is in charge and so
when we can't tolerate our comedians
it's like well there you go they're the
Canaries in the coal mine as far as I'm
concerned
[Applause]
you know I thought I promised my wife
that I wouldn't hit any Hornets with any
Hornets nests with sticks for like a day
and now I just hit a big hornet's nest
with the stick so sorry Tammy she's here
somewhere
give it up for Jordan's wife by the way
she's been on this entire floor
all right so let's David's fault yeah
let's shift gears a little bit what what
has been the best part of this adventure
of this tour for you personally oh well
the best part happens all the time
the best part well I think I think I
told this story tonight
though I'm not sure because I talked to
a bunch of journalists today so can't
remember when I told this story but this
guy came up to me last night he was a
kind of a pierced guy rough looking guy
and about he's probably in his late 20s
maybe early 30s he said I've I've been
smoking drug-free for nine months and I
said hey good work man because he looked
pretty pleased about that I said well
you know hopefully that's a lot better
and he said it's a lot better
I said well good for you for sticking it
out and I hope you can continue it and I
meant that because I didn't mean good
for you and hope you can stick it out
and he knew I meant that because he
wouldn't have bloody well told me that
to begin with he didn't think that that
was going to be the response and then he
said I got nine of my mates to do the
same thing yeah I thought right on man
that's great and then you know this I
was in Birmingham two nights ago and I
walked out of the hotel on this kid
working-class kid came up to me you know
just out of the blue and he said thank
you very much for elevating my vision I
thought hey look it's really good thing
to be able to go around the world and
have people stop you on the street and
say things like that to you it's like
that's as good as it gets you know and
people are telling me stories like that
all the time they come up and they say
well you've watched this thing it helps
all the time people come up and they
tell me some way that their house was
out of order you know they're hopeless
and and nihilistic and and drinking too
much and watching too much pornography
and procrastinating too much and being
not serious with their relationship and
not getting along with their parents and
you know not formulating a vision and
not growing up and well you know there's
just endless ways that you can descend
into a kind of what would you call it a
kind of grungy filthy carpet in
did hell and and so and then they say
look I've been watching your lectures
and I I developed a plan for my life and
I've been trying to be more responsible
and I've been really trying to tell the
truth and I mended my relationship with
my father and I got married to my
girlfriend and now I have a flat and I
quit doing drugs and I've just tripled
my salary in the last year and and I
didn't commit suicide like I was going
to six months ago I think I have I don't
know out of the hundred and fifty people
that I talked to each night I would say
probably over the course of the lecture
series there's probably ten people like
that at night who tell me that and so
see him because I believe what I said
tonight I believe that the individual is
sovereign and that individual
sovereignty is the cornerstone of
reality itself and it's the cornerstone
of the state and it's the cornerstone of
reality itself I truly believe that to
be the case that every time I hear
someone say look I've got my act
together I think that's one more weight
on you know if the scales are always
tilting towards good or towards evil
then every time someone decides to
straighten themselves up they put a mate
they take a major weight off the evil
side and they put it on the good side
and it's not trivial and I believe that
that's what the redemption of the world
depends on it's not political it happens
at the level of the individual just like
the descent into totalitarian
catastrophe occurs when people abandon
their sovereign responsibility which I
think is the most accurate way of
diagnosing what happened in the 20th
century so whenever someone comes up to
me and says I was not doing so well and
here's you know three ways where I've
really put my life together we have a
little 15 second party and we both know
why and so that's that's as good as it
gets and so that's happening constantly
and I feel generally speaking that these
events are like their celebrations of
that and so interesting to watch the
media miss this completely it's like
they don't have the conceptual what
would you say they don't have
sexual tools to understand that
something might be happening that's
worthy of note outside the purely
conventional confines of you know that
the stultifying and dull political
discourse but it doesn't matter it might
be nice if it didn't happen it doesn't
fundamentally matter because I'm a
psychologist I decided a long time ago
that the individual was the right level
of analysis and so it's an absolute it's
it's not a pleasure it's not the right
way of thinking about it what's rule
seven do what is meaningful not what is
expedient this is the most deeply
meaningful thing that I can envision
doing so that's great it's great it's
hard great is hard when something great
happens that's hard right it's not it's
not something trivial but it doesn't
matter because because it's great and so
every time someone says to me I'm better
I am getting along with my father I've
married my girlfriend we're gonna have a
child we're gonna have children now
we're gonna have children
I think that's one more so that's great
[Applause]
tell the audience a little bit about
Jordan Peterson having fun we did
serious Jordan Peterson what's Peterson
doing for fun i stumped him actually
well it's not like I don't it's like
most of what I've always done for fun in
my life has been to play you know and so
when I had little kids I played with
them all the time and my kids are
growing up and I play with them all the
time and my daughter is so playful
despite her rather catastrophic life up
to this point she's much better but is
that every single thing she says you
know when she's not delivering like when
she's not focused on talking to people
about a serious topic everything she
says is a joke you know when my son is
ridiculously t'see and playful and so
and so that's fun and when they were
little kids we just played all the time
and so I really like that and most of
the people who beat my close friends
have been people like that they're there
they play with their speech all the time
which is why I think I get along with
comedians you know it's like it's partly
why we travel well together and John my
tour manager who's a great guy very very
useful he's also a comedian and Brogan's
a comedian and so many of the people
that I got along with our comedians and
and the best interviews I've had have
been with comedians because there's that
element of play so I really like that on
this tour there's not a lot of fun I
wouldn't say we had a good time when we
went to the comedy club in Salt Lake
City that was that was fun that was 45
minutes of fun and I had some fun at
Cambridge I had some fun just to be
clear I brought Jordan up as the
surprise guest I did about an hour a
stand-up and then I brought Jordan up
and we did we sort of did stand-up
together we just kind of rift for about
45 minutes and people were yeah it was
fun they were thrilled and they loved
seeing you laugh yeah well I did I was
at the Cambridge Union just a couple of
days ago and I was in a fairly
high-spirited mood
and I had a fair bit of fun with the
students there it was still serious but
you know what I really like what the
times in my life that I've had the best
time is when I'm sitting around with a
variety of people who are very amusing
and all they're trying to do is to
outwit each other with something absurd
and funny and it was really a part of I
don't know if it's a part of
Scandinavian culture or not but in in in
in the West where I grew up which is a
working-class culture
I mean most of what my friends and I did
with regards to conversation was like
half-witted up man up man [ __ ] I guess
that's what it is your goal was to say
something funnier than the person just
before you said and so it was
competitive humor and I really really
like that a lot and so when I'm able
that's great relief but this tour like
it's very tightly scheduled crazily
tightly scheduled and Tammy and I
decided at the beginning that because it
was such an absurd opportunity that it
was a working tour you know and that we
were going to subordinate everything to
making sure that these shows went as
well as they possibly could and that we
would take whatever refuge and amusement
we could you know where we could steal
it and and we've had some of that I mean
the last time we're in Oslo we walked up
to the sculpture gardens and so that was
really cool and we walked down the
Boulevard and we only had about an hour
and a half to take a look around the
city but but it was a nice hour and a
half you know the Sun was out and we
enjoyed ourselves and so that's rule 12
right petit cadeau on the street when
when you see one when you encounter one
and you take your joy where you can get
it and you don't complain if it's not
happening perhaps as often as it should
especially when you're given like we
have been this absolutely improbable
adventure and we'll have time hopefully
God willing
knock on wood with some luck for some
more fun in the future
well that's actually quite a segue to my
next question which is because you talk
about stories so much and the importance
of stories does the Jordan Peterson
story have a happy ending and does that
even matter or what do you think the the
ending of the Jordan Peterson story is I
don't have any idea you know when I was
from the time I was about 20 I kind of
had a sense of what would happen to me I
had some sense of it but only it really
only extended till I was about my age 50
something like that and I didn't know
what would I didn't have a vision for
after that and see I thought when I
wrote wrote maps of meaning I remember
telling one of my my peers I said I
think everyone will think the way that I
think in this book in 50 years and he
said well that's a pretty grandiose
claim I guess that was it something like
well fair enough you know but but but by
the same token I wasn't taking click I
wasn't taking credit for the ideas like
I was taking some credit for clarifying
them the ideas were already there
they're everywhere those ideas but
clarifying them is something and so I
knew that what I was working on in maps
of meaning was at the center of things
in some sense and that manifested itself
in my teaching career because well I
taught at Harvard for six years and the
course there which was based on my book
was very very popular and and students
regarded as life-changing and the same
thing happened at the University of
Toronto and so I knew that that power
was in those ideas but I don't see my
future very clearly from here on in
you know over the next year I'm going to
do more of what I'm doing I want to
return to the exodus to Exodus I like
doing those biblical lectures I thought
that was useful and important so I want
to do that but my vision kinds of kind
of runs out in December of 2019 and I
don't know what because all of this is
so unlikely you know I thought for the
last two years every single day I
thought well this is going to come to an
end like this is ridiculous and this is
ridiculous these can't continue but it
is continuing and so I have no idea how
do you predict something like that I
mean for the longest time I thought that
as this wave grew the probability that I
would end up like a surfer smashed on
the beach was the highest probability
outcome and I still probably think that
that's the highest probability outcome
but but I'm not as apprehensive about
that now as I was because in some sense
assuming I don't do anything spectacular
ly stupid like defend count dank EULA on
Dave Rubin
the people the people who would like to
that who would have liked to have taken
me out have thrown the worst that they
could throw at me as far as I can tell I
mean my my my Cardinal day in terms of
vilification it's quite a contest by the
way because there were many days like
that was the day where I was
simultaneously accused by a an all right
magazine of being a Jewish shill and
accused by a Jewish magazine of being
tantamount to Hitler himself I thought
well that pretty much does it it's like
the Nazis hate me because I'm a Jewish
shill and the and well this particular
Jewish publication you know compared me
to Hitler and I thought well that's it
there's where else do you go after that
we're gonna call me Mao it's like it's
there already you know that's just not
that much past Hitler and so you know
and so I'm not that concerned that in
the absence of some fatal stupidity on
my part which certainly could still
happen because we have that proclivity
for fatal stupidity within all of us I'm
not too concerned that I'm going to be
taken out by my ideological opponents
but by the same token this is a pretty
unwieldy and unprecedented situation to
be in and so I'm not under any illusions
about its stability or safety so who
knows man well I'll stick with you as
long as you'll keep me so good alright
so I promised you guys that I was gonna
take what I thought was the best
question from you guys and there were
there were hundreds of them I was
reading through him during the lecture
but I thought this was the best we got
out of Oz will you move to Oslo and run
for Prime Minister of Norway
[Applause]
well first you probably want someone who
can speak Norwegian and second more
seriously throughout my life I've
considered a political career and
certainly when I was young very
seriously that was my ambition till I
was about 18 but yeah it started but now
I ran for a an executive position in the
Socialist Party in my home province when
I was 14 and so that was the first
large-scale public speech I gave to
about 700 people
wait can everyone pause for one second
try to picture 14 year old socialist
Jordan Peterson
that's an incredible image to me what
was that kid like like me you know I I
could speak to a crowd then speech was
very successful
I lost the position by 13 votes out of
700 something like that and you know I
had the audience under I had the
audience know so you know there's
certain things about you that remain
constant hopefully I know more than I
did then you know that's to be devote we
hoped for
I stopped actively pursuing a political
career when I was 18 and the reason for
that was because I became more
interested in something else which is
what I was talking about tonight because
it turned out that the political
problems that I was interested in were
were deep enough arguably not to be
political because they were really for
some reason I was very interested in
totalitarianism right from the time I
was like an adolescent I don't know why
exactly
who the hell knows why you get
interested in what you're interested in
some problem you know this is a thing
that's useful to know about life you
know all of you have problems that
bother you and you think well I don't
want to have a problem and fair enough
but like there's a whole lot of problems
you could have that could bother you
because there's lots of things wrong
with the world and you could be obsessed
by like a million problems right because
there's just problems everywhere but
you're not some problems grab you why
it's a mystery it's the mystery of the
autonomy of being in some sense the
problem grabs you and it won't let you
go it's like that's their suffering in
that that's your problem and you know in
that problem might be your destiny I
think that's right is in the problems
that grip you are the portal to your
destiny and and so well then you can
accept them it's like what are you gonna
have no problems good good luck with
that so you've got your problems one of
the things you learn as a therapist is
you don't interfere with people's
problems and what I mean by that is this
let's say you come to me and you know we
have a discussion about what's going
wrong in your life and I listen because
I want you to explain what the problems
are because what do I know about your
life it's like I need to listen so that
I can hear what your problem is and not
rush to a conclusion and then I want to
listen well you generate a solution now
I'm gonna help by asking questions and
help you explore but if I let's say you
lay out your problem and I think hey I
know what would fix that and then I just
say to you well you know here's the
solution well first of all you're gonna
be very annoyed about that because I
just took your problem and and it was up
to you to wrestle with that problem and
come up with a solution and then to have
a little self congratulatory burst of
pleasure at your own intuitive genius
that you could solve your problem and
then then you're motivated because
you've come up with the solution
you go implement it right and so well so
my problem became something that wasn't
political and so I pursued that and so
I'm not going to pursue a political
career and I've also decided to I didn't
know this but I don't have the
temperament for it I couldn't do it
I find the adversarial interviews that
I'm in for example they take me like it
takes me three days to recover from one
of those well it does because I don't
like that mode of discourse and if your
political you're in that mode of
discourse all the time and I'm not cut
out for it
like I'm not a particularly combat of
person by nature I'm a person who's
terrified about leaving monsters under
the rug ignored but that is not the same
thing and it's not like I enjoy the
process of calling them out and hashing
them through but I think well better get
out them well they're small so so so no
I'm not coming to Norway that's the
answer to that question so all right
well on that note I've said this to you
privately before but I may as well say
it publicly since we're putting this up
on the YouTube this what we're doing
here this started as a professional joy
for me but it has become a personal joy
that I can't explain I am better than
when we started like I know what it's
like to be these people that taking
these ideas in and changing and I'm
veterans and it's because of the work
that you've put into your life that
you've helped give to all of us so I
want to thank you for that and on that
note I've never ended a show like this
before but I'm gonna get out of the way
and I need you guys to go bananas for
dr. Jordan Peterson thank you guys
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]